Putin's problem was that he sat back and
let NATO expand for decades and that was
Russia's problem and it's like only now
they're willing to engage in military
conflict they've basically lost at this
point it's it's the craziest thing to me
that you would lose you know 50 of the
conflicted territory and then decide to
fight you lost already bro well but also
like they already got your border with
Estonia and Latvia now you're mad
because of Ukraine and gas prom but also
look at the Reliance on the Wagner group
okay which shouldn't be necessary for
world-class military and who is the
Wagner group it you know they're
plucking convicts out of prisons and
throwing them there and even the uh
after the the call-up order that one
went down in September I think it was uh
which met with some extraordinary
displays of resistance on the streets of
Moscow and elsewhere
um you know the reports are that uh and
this is also verified by interception of
uh of signal Communications between
soldiers at the front and their families
and so on but